joining me on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line fresh off a big w in
cincinnati ohio getting set to take on
the new york football giants in sofie
stadium is none other than the
quarterback of the los angeles chargers
back on the rich eisen show justin
herbert how are you doing justin always
great to be back doing well thank you
really appreciate you saying that so uh
let's jump jump into it how do you view
your 2021 season as we enter week 14.
how do you do that it's a great question
you know and i think uh one of the great
things about our team is we've played
some really good football and at times
you know we haven't played as great at
football and those are the moments that
you watch the film and you have to learn
from and um yeah we're going to make
mistakes but our team's going to learn
from them and you know i think we've
come a long way and there's still a lot
of football left so uh to what do you
attribute the inconsistency that you
refer to
i think it's just the nfl i think you're
going up against some pretty tough
competition and every every week you're
going to go against a team that's well
coached
and they're going to have studs on the
defense and offense so it's all about
how you prepare and having a good week
of
protection plans and talking about
coverage and doing all those things that
matter so that you have any chance on
sundays what is the general sense of the
coverage you see
consistently from the defenses in the
nfl forcing you to do something
maybe they're gonna see a whole lot of
different coverages you'll see cover
three you're gonna see some uh
you know split split safety looks cover
two and you're gonna see a lot of man as
well especially with the guys that we
have on the outside mike williams team
now and um you know you're gonna get
their best shot so it's all about having
a good week preparation and getting
ready for those nights what is the
general sense of what you think they're
trying to get you to do that what's your
that trying to get you out of
your potential comfort zone do you see a
general a consistency amongst the way
defenses are playing you at all that's a
good question i i think all defenses
kind of play us differently and one week
it might be
a lot of single high safety in the next
week it might be a lot of uh too high
safety so uh it's all about game
planning and seeing what team does what
um and prepping for those guys because
you know i think they all do play a
little bit differently which is the
toughest defense you've seen this year
then uh there have been a few you know i
think new england's got a really good
defense they're really well coached and
you know they do a great job of
disguising everything and making one
thing look like another and um you know
they've had a lot of success on defense
okay so the patriots the one that stands
out to you did you see that uh any of
the monday night game justin got to
watch that one and uh it was really a
close game came down to the wire so uh
it's always a lot of fun to watch yeah i
mean you know what
what do you think's going through mac
jones's head as he throws it only twice
in an evening justin what was that love
what is that like i think that's a tough
situation quarterback you know you
always love to throw the ball but you
have to do anything you can to win the
game and um you know they found a way to
win the game by only throwing the ball
three times so a really impressive job
so uh when you go and you went into
cincinnati and it's joe barrow and you
and you're part of the same draft class
do you think at all that uh i want to
beat this guy and just show somebody if
anybody needs anything to be proven
justin any of that sort of pride on the
line last weekend for you you know i
think going into the game you want to
win every game um you know i got to know
joe it's a combine and he's a great guy
and we got to spend some time together
talking and
you know i'm always rooting for him he's
a he's a guy that i'll be cheering for
for the rest of his career and excited
to see where he can where he can go but
you know i think every week you look to
try and win the game and
i don't think there was anything more
because of it
i just have a lot of respect for that
team and that quarterback as well justin
herbert here on the rich eisen show from
the los angeles chargers getting ready
for the giants so um for you what are
you better at do you think this year
that last year either just your your
greenness being in the league or
anything else
lent uh to to this being your step
forward this year what's the biggest
step forward for you this year justin
yeah i think uh i think playing with
timing is one of those things that i
worked really hard this offseason
our quarterback coach shane day and i
we spent a lot of time working on our
drops and how every route is tied to the
the timing of the drop
you know if you do have to wait a little
bit longer make sure you hitch and move
your feet independently and being able
to ready and and throw those balls on
time but um you know i think having a
feel for the pocket being able to step
up kind of quick movements uh to avoid a
defender i think i've gotten better at
that and what about sticking in the
pocket longer i mean like your your game
against the steelers was significant for
not just your throwing but your running
as well but that's kind of seemingly an
outlier this year you were running a lot
more last year what about that justin
yeah i think that's maybe just an
instinct thing um you know if the pocket
gets
split um defenders aren't looking at you
and there's plenty of space you take off
and you run and um you know we'd love to
be able to convert every third down and
whether that's through the air through
the ground
you have to find a way to complete those
third downs and i i thought we did a
great job of kind of reacting to that
pocket being able to take off and run
and get some yarns
so brandon staley this year
has brought a different mix obviously
than your first year what uh what has he
done with you do you think that has
helped you to where you are right now
going into week 14. justin yeah he comes
into our quarterback room all the time
just talks defense and he's got such a
great feel for defenses and especially
his own and the way they run it on on
our field and um just talking with him
and picking up so much about you know
leverage and
where the linebackers are gonna line up
and what they're trying to hide what
they're trying to disguise
we've learned a ton from him okay and
you know so much was made during your
draft period of that
uh that um
that piece of paper that you you or your
homework or what have you when you were
a kid that you grew up wanting to be a
quarterback uh in the nfl of the
chargers is this this sort of stuff
through the first year and plus that you
dreamt of i mean is this the dream that
you were you're thinking of as a kid
that you're actually realizing it just
it it's still unbelievable to realize
where i am and um you know i just have
to thank all the people that helped me
get here and i didn't do it alone and i
thank my parents my mom and my dad my
brothers my grandparents and
especially all the coaches i've had
along the way that have kind of molded
me into the quarterback that i am today
and i'm still so much
room for improvement i can get so much
better um but you know it's an honor to
be here like what seriously like what
what are you talking about room for
improvement what what what what can you
improve upon right now justin
we can always limit turnovers um you
know i can always get the ball out
quicker and
you know i think even having a better
understanding of defenses and being able
to check and go through audibles and do
all that um stuff you know i think
that's the next step in the quarterback
play and stuff that you can always
improve on who's the one who yells for
the ball the most in the huddle
from you
i think the great part about our
receivers is no one really yells for the
ball okay so then let me just that that
might be a that might be it's too strong
who's the most vocal vociferous then
let's use that word who's who's the one
that speaks up saying i'd like it more
than not
yeah i think keenan now and mike
williams are those guys that want to
compete for the ball every single play
and you know i think they're two very
special players and and on third down
especially you need to be able to look
for them because something special is
going to happen and that's kind of what
you want from your competitors like that
to be able to go up and get the ball and
fight for the ball and want the ball
okay it seems that uh at home you know
uh
it seems that the on the road let's put
it this way you guys are a little bit
more consistent and focused what what's
going on at home a little bit more for
you justin obviously you're not shut out
at home but uh it just seems to me i've
been a few of your games and i've seen a
few on the road it seems different is
there something going on that we need to
know about at all i don't think there's
anything different i think you can take
a look at uh the raiders film the the
pittsburgh steelers film and our offense
is playing pretty well those days and
brown you know i think we'd love yeah
especially
i think it's one of those things that
you'd love to be able to compete as well
as you can every single game but that's
the nfl and you have to learn from it
and as tough as it may be and not being
able to move the ball sometimes
you have to get better from it and you
know i think you have your your
your low games your low points but you
always have to bounce back and be ready
for the next one justin herbert here a
couple minutes left with the los angeles
chargers quarterback here on the rich
eisen show what do you think about
what's going on at your alma mater now
looking for a new coach who uh has left
for uh the university of miami what do
you think about that justin
i think it's always a tough situation
you know coach crystal and i were we
were really close and you know i really
loved playing for him and um you know
you can't fault the guy he he uh he has
a great opportunity to go coach there
back home and be with his mother and
you know i feel for all the guys at
oregon because you know they've they put
so much into it but i trust
administration i know they're gonna find
the right guy okay is there somebody in
in mind is there somebody you would want
to pound the table for justin you do
have a little bit of sway even just
saying something publicly so
what do you have anything i uh i haven't
done enough research yet so if at the
end of the year when football's over and
and they're still looking for a coach
i'll help you hey you'll be part of this
that's to be part of the search okay
yeah all right
and honestly i think you're playing uh
remarkably well not just because of of
who you are and who you represent but i
don't know if you're aware you are the
quarterback of both of my fantasy teams
uh i appreciate that that means the most
to me well you know i i've put a lot of
faith in you uh justin there's no
question about it and right now one of
those teams is 11 and two and uh you and
keenan are on that team together so
um do me a favor mention that to coach
staley and uh and and apologize to mike
williams when you have to you know throw
it to 13. will you mind would you mind
doing that a little bit what do you
think i'll uh i'll get that taken care
of i love it i love it terrific okay i
like it
all right and now you're not touching
your hair this year right this is it
what we're seeing this time that uh that
wasn't the plan for this year so uh
was it in the plan for last year i don't
know if it was in the plan for last year
even no it technically wasn't so i think
that's just something that uh it kind of
came up but okay i'll have to address
that after the year okay very good
that's another after the year addressing
take care of yourself justin herbert
appreciate the time you be well sir
awesome thank you very much right back
at you that's justin herbert los angeles
chargers quarterback right here on the
rich eisen show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here